once you have a set of your apis
outfitted with api proxies now is the
time to share them with your developers
so that they can start consuming them in
apogee
we refer to the process of getting your
apis
into the hands of your developers as
publishing your apis
publication requires the following three
steps
creating api products registering
developers
and registering apps here's how it works
in apigee an api product is a set of api
proxies
that you want to bundle together to
offer to your app developers create
different api
products to address different app
developer needs
app developers are your api's customers
so treat creation of an api product as
you would
any other product you'd offer to a
customer
next to be able to give app developers
access to your api
products you'll need to register your
app developers
if you have a developer portal app
developers can register themselves
if you don't have a developer portal you
can use the apogee edge api
to provide a registration form for app
developers
or you can register them yourself using
the apogee edge ui
the final step in enabling a developer
to access your api product
is to register a developer app again if
you have a developer portal
an app developer can register her app
herself
if you don't have a developer portal you
can use the apogee edge api
to provide an app registration form for
app developers
or you can register the app on your
developer's behalf
using the apogee edge ui when
registering her app
the developer selects the api products
that her app needs to access
once registered the developer is given a
consumer key
also known as a public key api key
or app key each app has a single key
that provides access to all api products
associated with the app the app
developer
codes her app to present the key to be
able to access the api product
this is the simplest form of app-based
security that you can configure for an
api
another useful feature of these keys is
that you can revoke a key
to prevent an app from accessing one or
all of the api products
with which it is associated and there
you have it
products developers and developer apps
and their keys
working in conjunction to provide
targeted access to your apis
to your app developers to learn more
about apogee
products developers and developer apps
please see the links provided